I got a question for you. Okay, we we
we've done the Protestants. Sam Sam
Shimoon sitting in an airport.
An atheist recognizes you and he sits
next to you
and he goes to you convince me that
there's a God and convince me that he's
your god. Atheism. Now, what are you
doing? What's your first step?
My first step is say here's how you're
going to prove that the god of
Christianity doesn't exist. Falsify the
origin of the church. What do I mean?
People under underappreciate
the fact that the church began by
claiming a dead man came to life and was
made immortal. Paul says if Christ has
not been raised, give up your faith. Go
party. So if tomorrow they were, and
it's never going to happen because Jesus
is alive. He's almighty. He is alive.
He's reality. But let's say tomorrow
they found the bones of our Lord and
they proved it. father would now have to
stop being a because Paul said a me and
father will go to the nightclub
right I mean it's not going to happen so
don't worry about father it's not going
to happen
believe he's not worried he didn't come
this far Sam to worry about that
but you know what I'm saying Paul said
it in 1 Corinthians 15 he said if Christ
has not been raised your faith is
useless says in 1 Corinthians 15 he goes
eat drink and be marry go party cuz
tomorrow you die
you're starting with a Christian God.
He's telling you, I don't even believe
that a God exists.
No, that's what I'm saying. So, it's
okay. I'm not trying to convince you of
just the Christian God. I want you to
convince me to be an atheist by
explaining away the origin of the
church.
Give me some naturalistic explanation
for the origin of the church. Because
the followers of Christ claimed that man
who was beaten, bloodied, buried,
appeared to them alive physically,
and the tomb was discovered empty. And
that appearance convinced them he's now
alive physically, and they're willing to
be killed for that claim.
Skinned alive, crucified upside down.
Yes.
Yeah. That's what that's what so so
convince me how the church began by
giving me an explanation that rules out
the resurrection because any explanation
you give will not account for the
church. See this is why people
underappreciate the church's existence.
History has a test that when you have
false mess messianic claimments, when
they're killed, their movement dies
or their followers are killed with them
and that's it. I mean, here I'll give
you example. Bar KBA,
he was a second century messianic
claimment
who led an uprising against the Romans.
And there was a rabbi named Rabbi Aka
who called him Barakbar, meaning the son
of the star, a messianic title, because
he thought, "Oh, that's our Messiah."
It's around 130 AD. He got vanquished
and crushed like a grape. Does anyone
talk about him?
Rabbi Aka said his name was Bara or he
goes that's barbar, the son of star.
Because in numbers 24:17 talks about the
star rising. And they take that as
Messiah. Go here. He is the Messiah. He
got crushed like a grape. No one hears
about him. So if Jesus was killed and
buried, how do you explain for the
origin of the church? And on top of
that, another piece of evidence, even
someone like Bart, who is an atheist,
but as an historian will tell you, first
Corinthians, 1 Corinthians, Paul wrote
it around 55 AD. 55 AD. 55 AD. That's
within 20 years of Jesus resurrection in
1 Corinthians 1:2. See, these are things
we underappreciate as Christians. He's
talking to Greeks, Gentiles along with
Jews. And he says that they are known
for all of known for calling on the name
of our Lord Jesus Christ, both their
Lord and ours.
Greetings to all whom everywhere call
upon the name of our Lord Jesus Christ.
Now, why is that astonishing? See, when
we read it, yeah, we know he's God.
Understand the historical context. What
would lead a group of monotheistic Jews,
Paul being one of them, his conversion
itself has to be explained, to call on a
Jew who less than 20 years earlier had
been killed and buried and now call on
his name when that phrase calling on the
name is an Old Testament formula where
Old Testament saints called on the name
of Jehovah.
All throughout the Old Testament, you'll
see Abraham built an altar and called on
the name of the everlasting God. Genesis
21:33, right? Joel 2:32, "Whoever calls
on the name of Jehovah shall be saved."
Here you have within 20 years of Jesus's
crucifixion.
Paul is saying, "We Jews and you
Gentiles, when we gather, we're known
for this practice. Wherever we are, we
all come to do this. call on the name of
our Lord Jesus Christ. So secondly, what
would lead Greeks, Gentiles to stop
worshiping Zeus and Hermes, stop going
to the temples and sacrificing, being
imprisoned and killed for it, to call on
the name of a Jew who wasn't even one of
their own ethnically whom they knew had
been killed 20 years earlier. What in
the world would cause them to do that?
See, we have a miracle in our hand. It's
called the church. and the mass
conversion of monotheistic Jews and thou
the Greeks were being killed because to
not sacrifice to the gods would incur
the wrath of the gods. So they would be
afraid. Hey, hey, you know you're going
to get Zeus angry, right? You better.
No, no, no, no. Zeus is is Satan. We
worship Jesus. What would lead Greeks to
worship a Jew as their god? He's not
even Greek. He's a Jew.
Without the resurrection, there is no
good answer. Mhm.
I never thought of starting there with
an atheist to be honest with you.
Yeah, explain it to me. I'll be an
atheist.
Yeah, I got you. So, you you don't go
with Big Bang and who put the rocks and
the gas there and all that stuff.
I mean, because that's been done. And
yes, our existence itself is a testimony
to an intelligent designer. You have to
be taught not to believe God created
this. But see, I just cut to the chase.
I said, "Hello, I'll make it easier for
you. I'm a sinner who struggles with
sin.
And I don't want to be answerable to
Christ because I'm going to have to
answer for how I lived. You would make
it so easy easy for me to be
disconvinced that the God revealed in
Jesus exists so I can now live the way I
want like a heathen. Go stuff myself at
buffets and not care.
Explain to me the origin of the church.
How did it come into being? Even
atheists have to admit there are several
atheist historian. There are historians
in historical Jesus. They all admit yes
one one renowned scholar his name is
Gard Ludman and even Bartman. These are
atheists but they study the historical
evidence. They all admit yes the
followers of Jesus were convinced they
saw him alive physically and that he's
in heaven physically. And Bartman even
gives some names. He goes, "Peter, Mary
Magdalene, and a few others did actually
see something that convinced them they
were seeing Christ alive physically and
he's in heaven physically." But then
they say, "Well, we don't know
why they saw what they saw, but they did
say something to convince them that God
was was alive. Christ, who's God in the
flesh, was alive, and then put a fire on
them to go preach it and convert people
and die for it." Well, if they were
hallucinating, then why did someone
produce the body?
It's unsettled.
Yeah. Because the proclamation, here's
what's beautiful about Christianity. The
proclamation Christianity did not start
in Rome. It started at the very place
where Christ was killed in Jerusalem.
The last place you can get away with
Christ being raised is the very place
where thousands of people are still
there who had either seen or had family
members tell them because they were
there. Christ was killed and he was
buried. The last place you're going to
get away with that he's been raised is
there.
Because all they need to do is produce
the body.
But no body, right?
No body.
I mean, I can go into the arguments for
the empty tomb, but I'm simplifying it.
Mhm. Okay. So, just watching you talk
about this and many things, I see
passion. Sam's a passionate man, right?
Because I'm an angry man. I was I came
out of my mother's womb angry. So,